we know the potentials of AI imagine
living in a world where AI has taken
over and it's woke AI can enforce its
political woke agenda far more than
government and big Tech can I was
literally using chat GPT the other day
and I typed in something about
traditional masculinity and it replied
to me telling me that traditional
masculinity is bad that's outrageous why
is traditional masculinity bad well
that's the messaging that's coming from
the major AI companies like open AI chat
GPT I also asked chat GPT about the
JibJab and it told me that it was safe
and effective as more data is coming out
we obviously know this isn't the case so
now ai is pushing the government's woke
agenda it's so concerning you just need
to look at any dystopian movie because
all these dystopian movies are just
predicting the future